Jessica's in Raleigh North Carolina hi
Jessica
how are you better than I deserve what's
up in your world not much I'm calling
because I stay at home my husband works
and I have a business idea that I want
to get out in the world but it requires
a lot of setup cause we're on baby set
two now so we're kind of just like weird
we don't have extra money to kind of
throw at this but we also don't want to
be done starting a business if we don't
have money now that would be dumb so
what what is it how much setup cost
doing my research so it's a kids play
place that focuses on birthday parties
so what we want to create has a lot of
large indoor structures and
customization of play structures so it's
looking to be around 180,000 you get all
of the stuff in there so that's that's
why I'm done before you know that right
it's what that's been done before you
know that right this kind of business
oh yeah that's all over the place right
right but we're like the kind of
business I want to do that the birthday
party rooms is going to what keeps us
higher than every bounce house and pizza
place in America has a birthday party
right they do I wouldn't argue they're
just nasty grody in a lot of cases I
don't argue that so the only difference
though in your thing is cleanliness and
quality of play no it would actually be
experience so what we wanted to do is
make we want to create themed party
rooms so that when parents come in they
don't need any kind of decor anything
like that you're running a room that is
like superhero themed so it's a room
designed for that party
type of party well the way only way I
would do it obviously is pay cash for it
it's an ultra high-risk business that
you're entering into because your brand
differentiation is not as great as it is
you view it is in my mind I don't say
I'm not saying it can't work and I'm not
saying don't live your dream but don't
let your dream turned into a nightmare
because it's not going to turn out
exactly like you think it's going to it
never does in business so pay cash for
it as you go and you're not in a
position to do that today I wonder if
there's a way to do this on a part-time
basis and think about a different way to
get an angle on it
send you a copy of Christie Wright's
book business boutique equipping women
to make money doing what they love and
see if that'll give you some heads up
ideas